this is a production of cornell
university
hello my name is carl scamenti with the
cornell turfgrass program
back with another video in our series
highlighting our erp project
which aims to improve best management
practice adoption at golf courses in new
york state and this video series has
been focusing on
bmps being implemented at golf courses
in our region
today we're going to focus on battle
island golf course which is a state park
18-hole facility
uh
up in fulton new york about 45 minutes
north of syracuse
and so what they're doing up at battle
island
is some pretty basic measuring of
putting surface growth rate uh and i
think the place to start here is first
of all
to explain why it's important to measure
growth rate
i think one thing most superintendents
do
is to make decisions on fertilizer you
know rates and timings based on the
amount of growth they're seeing right so
instead of just a scheduled you know
tenth of a pound of n every two weeks or
every week
being able to be flexible
reacting to growth if growth is too high
scaling back on fertilizer and
you know conversely if growth is too low
scaling up i think most superintendents
have a
knowledge of that and they have a
general sense of growth rates um whether
that's
asking your operator in the morning how
many times you dumped
the baskets right or
or if you're just looking at in the
baskets to see the
amount of clipping buildup
that's a general sense of growth but i
think what we've wondered is is that a
good enough sense
and after doing some growth rate stuff
in the last couple years i think the
analogy i would draw is
um it's kind of like this general sense
is kind of like asking a tour pro in a
tour event
um when they're approaching when they're
hitting their approach out into the
green
that instead of getting exact yardage
hey just round to the nearest yardage
marker
um and of course for a tour pro rounding
to
you know 150 or 200 yards
isn't going to work out for them right
they're very precise they're very
accurate and how they can control their
distance it's why they're talking about
you know 177 or 178
they have the tools to be very exact
they have the skill to be very exact
and because of that they need an exact
yardage and i think when we talk about a
general sense of growth
i think we have the tools to be very
precise in how we control growth and
that necessitates a very accurate
measurement of growth
and one way you can do that is by
measuring clipping volume
this is very simple as you can see we
have a bucket
and what you do for putting greens is
you mow the green you dump the grass in
the bucket
you measure you know how what volume is
in there
um you record it and you track it
right very simple and
and this is what we set up at battle
island uh here's the 16th green that
we did our growth measurements on in
2021
you know a couple reasons we chose the
screen one it's about an average
performing green on the golf course so
it's fairly representative
uh and two you can see in the background
here there's a there's a bath house that
has a
uh storage space and that's where we
kept the the clipping bucket and the
recording sheet so that it stays dry and
that
you know when the mower finishes mowing
the screen we can drive right over there
dump the grass in the bucket get a good
measurement
and be able to repeat that process on a
daily basis
so we did this for for uh 2021 growing
season and
this is the data
so you can see the data is transformed
into a milliliters per meter squared
number so that's basically the volume of
the grass
divided by the the area
of the of the green if you were to
measure two or three greens this is a
way that you can
equalize the growth rates and compare
them apples to apples right because some
greens are bigger and smaller
and you can see kind of one of the
the most easiest things to observe here
in this data is
a lot of variability right and this is
the case with
almost every
uh course we've seen clipping data for
um there's high points there's low
points
so what do we what do you really do with
the data first of all um
you know i think the place to start is
just being
kind of aware during the season of when
the ideal putting surface
conditions when those are occurring at
what growth rates
um so a battle islands between 5 and 15
milliliters per meter squared
at most golf courses you'll be able to
pretty early on
identify when your greens are performing
the best
and at what growth rates
you can achieve those at
what happens is if you're below these
growth rates right right here
that typically happens during tournament
conditions right you're stressing the
turf it's going to grow less
you're going to get great playing
conditions then but can you sustain that
right can you sustain the traffic and
the wear and tear on the turf when it's
not growing that much right probably not
on the other end of things if you're if
you're above that sort of goldilocks
zone
you'll get slower putting greens right
it's growing more you'll get more
organic matter accumulation right that
means softer greens conditions
um
so you know i think the first thing to
notice if you're going to do this is
just observe you know at what growth
rates you're achieving the ideal playing
surface conditions
and then it's time to look at okay why
are we getting
growth rates outside of those
right and you can look at your your
plant growth regulator program your
fertilizer applications
but one thing i've found with
any course that has native push-up soil
greens at least up here in new york
is there's a very strong correlation
between large rain events
and spikes in growth rate
right and the reason for that is most
likely the mineralization of
uh that native soil that native organic
matter material
right as you get big rain events there's
a lot of moisture especially in here in
the summer where there's
enough warmth in the system too
you get that microbial community just
mineralizing a ton of nitrogen it's
pumping nitrogen into the turf
and you get these spikes and growth
right after large rain events right
so this is something that that i would
encourage most people to just kind of
look at
their first year of clipping volume
collection
and just observe the first year right
and that's what we did at battle island
just kind of observed figure out hey
where can we make adjustments to improve
our playing conditions
and then you kind of come up with a plan
and start to implement a couple things
in the next year so
a couple of things you could do
right you could increase your pgr use
whether that's upping the rates to
achieve more
growth suppression and maybe using a
different plant growth regulator that
gives you more
suppression
obviously you're going to look at your
fertilizer rates and timings right if
you're seeing a growth spike in your
data hey hold off on that next nitrogen
application
um moisture management is critical right
so
as we saw there there's a pretty good
correlation between
uh large rain events and spikes in
growth so any way you can kind of
improve your moisture management you
know wetting agents that probably means
cultural practices right getting some of
that native soil out of the profile
i'm getting more sand in there so you
can control moisture
a little bit better
these are all things that
you can kind of implement as you go
along as you see the data
and hopefully will lead to
a more accurate
control of your growth rate and that
means more control over your putting
surface conditions
so uh you know for more information
about this case study we have a link
below to the document that will explain
a little bit more
and go through the data a bit more i
hope you learned something today and
please check out our other videos in our
erp series
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu